[Music]
hello friends and welcome to i'd like to
know
some tv the live broadcast specific
standard time
that answers your questions my name is
pastor james rafferty i'm here with
pastor
stephen bohr and we are excited to get
to
some of the many questions that have
been coming in
from all over the world it looks like
now we just want to remind you as we get
started
if you have questions that you would
like to have answered from the bible by
the bible
we can take an attempt to do that
by listening by responding to your
questions i'm losing all my wording here
if you email us at tv some tv.org that's
tv at some tv dot org
definitely got that email address right
so we're going to begin with the word of
prayer pastor boy if you'd like to have
prayer for us
let's pray father in heaven we come
before your awesome throne
with humility in the name of our beloved
savior jesus
amen because we know that we when we
come in jesus name
you incline your ear to hear and to
answer
and so as we try to answer these
questions with your word we ask for the
guidance of your holy spirit
give us clarity of thought give us open
hearts
and i ask lord that you will bless all
of those who are tuned in
that as they hear the answers to the
questions that might not only be
academic
but might have an impact on their
personal lives
thank you for hearing our prayer for we
ask it in jesus name
amen amen
okay pastor rafferty i have several
questions here we're not going to be
able to answer them all
in this program but the first one is
very interesting
okay it comes
from outside the united states i won't
mention the specific country
but this is the question matthew 28 19
go ye therefore and teach all nations
baptizing them in
the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy ghost
according to the above verse whosoever
follows christ
is supposed to baptize so all followers
of christ
supposedly are supposed to baptize why
do we have pastors alone baptizing
if i baptize isn't it wrong if i don't
isn't it in disobedience with the lord's
command
that's an interesting question let's
take a look at the verses shall we
you know it's always good to start with
the context of the bible verses
themselves matthew chapter
28 verse 19 i think there was a
statement made
in that question that
might have been a little bit of an
assumption i don't know i'm just going
to
assume that and that is um the idea that
this verse
is commanding all the followers of
christ
to baptize i think that's a little bit
of an assumption you know it's very
clear when you
look at the context of this verse that
it begins in verse 16
that's the immediate context that i
think is significant for us
that it begins with the 11 disciples now
jesus had 12 disciples but there were
only 11
because at this point judas had betrayed
christ
and then had committed suicide so the 11
disciples that are left
these are the ones that in verse 16 went
away
into galilee into the mountain where
jesus had appointed them
so jesus actually appointed them to meet
him at a certain place he didn't appoint
the whole church there were many other
believers at this time just the 11
disciples
and they were ordained and they were
ordained they had been ordained the 12
were ordained
11 were left here right but they had
hands
laid on the hands of christ laid on them
in separation
from the general group of believers good
point
and then he when they saw him they
worshipped him verse 17 says but some
doubted and then it says
jesus came and he spake unto them saying
all power is given unto me in heaven and
earth go ye therefore and teach all
nations baptizing them in the name of
the father
and of the son of the holy ghost
teaching them to observe all things
whatsoever i have commanded you and lo i
am with you always
even unto the end of the world so i
think just the context of this verse
tells us
that christ is specifying the baptizing
the teaching
to his ordained disciples
does that make sense yes absolutely you
know there are other places in the bible
where we see
this organizational structure
gospel order we could call it first
corinthians chapter 12
and ephesians chapter four talks about
christ setting up an organized church
with apostles and prophets and teachers
and then
you know adding more to the body and i
think we don't want
anyone to misunderstand this i think
everyone is involved in the gospel
commission
pastors can't baptize people without
the church body reaching out and
touching the lives and hearts of people
and giving bible studies and be involved
in that great commission so the great
commission
in that sense is for everyone but in the
context of
what all of scripture says you have
leadership
ordained leadership working with the
laity
and they have specific responsibilities
that are given to them as leaders and
part of those responsibilities
is baptizing yeah so
the disciples according to the gospels
forsook their everyday endeavors
and they became full-time missionaries
so it's just not a case of everybody in
the church that has all different kinds
of jobs you know
and they can end up baptizing whoever
they want
right there's discipline and there's
order in the church
and you know there are exceptions i
before i was an ordained pastor i would
do bible studies with people and i was
in full-time ministry
and but i wasn't an ordained pastor but
there were times when i would study with
people and they really wanted me to
baptize them
and so the church has made allowances
for that you can go to the church and
say hey this person really wants me to
baptize them is there any way that can
can happen right normally an ordained
pastor is in the water
with the layperson who's baptizing that
person they've studied with
and that's totally acceptable but it's
still an organizational structure
that that is set up there and there's
still this understanding of
you know this this structure that god
has ordained or set up right right
uh philip the evangelist obviously he
was a full-time evangelist
and he baptized the ethiopian eunuch yes
you know that's
one of the examples of someone who was
involved in full-time ministry
you know ellen white mentions a very
interesting case
there was a missionary that went to
pitcairn
that island in the south pacific and
he did an evangelistic series and
practically the whole island accepted
the message
yes but he wasn't ordained so basically
uh you know he
he said i can't baptize you folks
because i'm not ordained
well later on ellen white wrote a letter
and rebuked him
and said you know you should have
baptized those people wow but of course
that doesn't mean
that everybody can baptize all the time
right there are special
circumstances where a lay person can do
a baptism when no one else is available
exactly
but it doesn't mean that just everybody
can baptize anybody because
the candidate needs to be examined to
make sure that the candidate
has embraced the message has formed a
personal relationship with christ
and so there needs to be an examining
agency to make sure that the person that
is joining the church
that you're not planting tears in the
church now we know there's going to be
tears in the church
but it's different to plant tears in the
church
and so what you're saying i think is
that there are exceptions to the rule
but those exceptions don't
break the rule and they're far in
between yes
the rule stands and that's what we see
in the bible there's another
a couple of verses i wrote here in first
corinthians i thought might
might be good to look at those first
corinthians chapter 12
just because they gave us a little bit
of a semblance
of the gospel order that god has set up
first corinthians 12
28 to 31.
first corinthians 12 28-31 that's just
this coming right at the tail end
of the organ organizational structure
that that paul is describing here
the the body of christ like a body and
he says that god has set
some in the church first apostles
secondarily prophets thirdly teachers
after that miracles then gifts and
healings and helps and governments and
diversities of tongues
are all apostles are all prophets or all
teachers or all workers of miracles
have all the gifts of healing do all
speak with tongues to all interpret
but covet earnestly the best gifts yet i
show unto you a more excellent way
what i think is interesting about these
verses is that the question was asked
well can't everyone baptize
well the rhetorical question that paul
is asking here is no
um not everyone is an apostle not
everyone is a is a
is is a teacher right there's been gifts
given to different people for different
purposes and not everyone has that same
gift not everyone is ordained
not everyone is put in a position where
they're to lead out in a church and
baptize members
and if in ephesians chapter four there's
actually
a hierarchy of gifts that are mentioned
in ephesians chapter four
um it says let me see if i can find
these verses here verse 11 11
says and he himself gave some to be
apostles
some prophets some evangelists
some pastors and teachers
for the equipping of the saints for the
work of ministry for the edifying of the
body of christ
till all come into the unity of the
faith and of the knowledge of the son of
god to a perfect man
to the measure of the stature of the
fullness of christ
so god has established different
functions in the church and pastors is
one of them and the pastors are the ones
that
care for the local church so they
are to supervise there to guard the
church
from having individuals who are unworthy
become members of the church
and we see also in that first
corinthians passage chapter 13.
i want to show you a more excellent way
and then he talks about love
you know and love doesn't exalt itself
you know sometimes we'll
why can't i baptize i want to be
ordained i want to be in that position
well
love doesn't exalt itself the principle
of love is a principle of service
and so we need to uh be in the position
that god has placed us in and not be
trying to clamor for something else
something more than what god has
given to us as a gift you know the new
testament seems to indicate that
the position of pastor is similar to the
position of priests in the old testament
and there were certain functions that
only the priests
could perform in the sanctuary the the
general populace couldn't
and you know those who aspired to be
priests so we know what happened with
them
the rebellion of korah dathan and abyram
yeah so we need to respect the gospel
order that god has established
and there's a high standard for pastors
and if you're
out there baptizing people and then they
see you doing things that you know
lay people you know sometimes can do
that pastors will say no that's
i'm i'm a pastor i have a standard that
god is calling me to and i have a
certain way
that i need to conduct myself and
conduct my life and not everyone is
called to that standard and so therefore
not everyone is called
to that responsibility well i think that
we've
pretty much exhausted this one so let's
take a look at the next question
the next question is very very
interesting
as all of the questions that are sent to
us
pastor i would like to ask you if you
have a responsibility to care
for the environment and if so
what do we have to do to fulfill god's
will
i say this because our society is used
to polluting
and abusing nature in everything we do
for example using the car or even
drinking bottled water
thank you pastor god bless you and the
ministry
so the question is about how christians
are supposed to care for the environment
what is our obligation and our duty
you know i think as christians and even
as seventh-day adventists who believe
jesus is coming to make a new heaven a
new earth
i don't think that relieves us of the
responsibility to care for the earth for
the planet that god has made even though
it's
sin polluted and for me
as i've done some research on this you
know i of course i recycle
cardboard and plastic and i try to do
all of the recycling that i can
but what i found is one of the greatest
ways
for a believer to
i guess contribute to a good environment
and you know if you want to talk about
because there's a lot of
politics involved in climate warming and
that whole movement so i want to be very
careful where i tread here but
just a simple uh understanding
and a biblical one is a vegetarian diet
i don't know if a lot of viewers
understand this but the research shows
that one of the greatest contributing
factor
probably over 50 percent uh one of the
greatest contributing factors to global
warming to climate change
uh is animal production for food
the amount of water that's used the
amount of feed that's given
the um the waste that comes from that
the
forests that are being destroyed
yeah the waste yeah and the forces have
been destroyed in order to
put grazing land out there um it's huge
it's much bigger than that the carbon
from from vehicles
much bigger the footprint is huge and
they've they've said that even if you
were to just be a vegetarian for one day
a week
just not eat meat for one day a week you
know we're living in an environment now
where
people it's unprecedented how much uh
meat people eat
compared to what it was before and and
what's interesting
is first timothy chapter four you know
there's a a couple of verses there that
talk about
in the last days people will hold
themselves off from the food that god
originally formed to be received with
thanksgiving of them which believe and
know the truth
and that original diet that god formed
for us was the vegetarian diet
and in the last days of vegetarian diet
has a huge impact
on our environment so i'm a vegetarian
full-time not just one day a week or two
days a week but seven days a week
365 days a year and i think that's a
great contribution to the environment i
also drive a hybrid so
oh that helps a little bit i think yeah
well you know i
as i look at it there are three
different kinds of motivations for
caring for the environment the first
is for survival okay
that's what's being you know panned out
over here is you know
if we don't care for the environment if
we don't pay attention to
climate change it used to be called
global warming right until the freeze in
texas
but but anyway you know if we don't do
that
in 10 years civilization is going to end
right that's an exaggeration some people
say 10 years others say just a little
bit longer but anyway
so one reason for doing it is for
survival
right the second reason and this is a
lot of environmentalists is because they
believe that nature
is god right they're pantheistic now
they're supposed to care for nature
because nature is divine because they
believe that
all of nature is god you know basically
it's the idea of pantheism right
well we don't believe that that's the
motivation for caring for creation at
all we don't believe it's for survival
necessarily
although that's important right we don't
believe that nature is god
and it is it is as sacred animals are
just as sacred as human beings right we
don't believe that
we believe that we should care for
animals of course but we don't believe
that they're equal to human beings
and the third way uh is
the correct biblical way and that is
that we are stewards of creation amen
in other words creation belongs to god
it doesn't belong to us
so we care for creation not because it's
god we care for creation because it is
god's
yes it belongs to god right and you know
how would you feel you know i don't even
know what kind of car you drive but
let's suppose that
you drove a beautiful mercedes-benz
brand new nice and shiny
and then and i came with a nail
and i started scratching your brand new
car i think you would be pretty much
offended
why because it's yours so how do you
think that god feels
when we totally beat up on nature and
are not careful
you know for example bottles water
bottles are mentioned here
millions and millions of water bottles
end up in the ocean
and end up you know in in the streets
and in the landfills
uh should christians be more careful in
that regard
i think so yeah let's use the glass box
yes let's use glass bottles
containers right and let's recycle
there's no reason why a christian cannot
recycle
uh you know you we have two bins out
here right outside the door
one is for recycling and the other is
for first
refuse so so we need to care for the
environment
definitely absolutely now my big big
bone to pick
is that the climate agenda
issue is being waived
in order to gain control yes and i want
to read just this one statement that we
find in the book councils for the church
page 343 because people say
the science is clear there is climate
change
and it's going to lead to the end of the
world right it's scientifically proven
they say
well the same individuals say that
evolution is scientifically proven
as creationists we know that science
that um that is a hypothesis
hypothesis evolution is a hypothesis
and uh climate change i believe there is
climate change there's no doubt about it
uh but what is the reason for climate
change
that's the big issue council's put to
the church page 343
the restraining spirit of god is even
now
being withdrawn from the world
hurricanes now she mentions
so-called natural disasters hurricanes
storms tempests fire and flood
boy have we seen those recently
hurricanes storms
tempests fire and flood
right disasters by sea and land
follow each other in quick succession
and now comes the key portion science
seeks to explain all these
[Music]
and then she says the signs thickening
around us
telling us of the near approach of the
son of god
are attributed to any other than the
true
cause wow in other words science
is giving the wrong explanation she says
yes these things are happening there's
hurricanes and there's storms
tempest fire and flood disasters by sea
and land she doesn't deny it
right but she says that science tries to
explain
all of these things but they don't give
the true cause
and then she speaks of the true cause
she says men cannot discern the sentinel
angels
restraining the four winds that they
shall not blow until the servants of god
are sealed
but when god shall bid his angels loose
the winds
there will be such a scene of strife as
no pen can picture
wow that's amazing yeah what a picture
what a picture so so here's the question
um the bible
mentions two of the greatest climate
changes in the history of the world the
first
was the flood i would say that was a
major climate event uh what was the
cause of the flood people were using too
many air conditioners and driving too
many cars right
well in those days the science was
the bible says it was it was definitely
the lord of course he used nature you
know he opened the floodgates of heaven
the earth broke open you know the fishes
of water the water the earth was filled
with water at that time so that came
up but it was definitely the lord but
why did the lord do it
because the wickedness of man was great
on the earth that's it so what is the
reason for climate change in the world
today
wickedness it's the wickedness of men
one of the
things is that man is not caring for the
environment right
and for animals absolutely for animals
wickedness against animals cruelty
against animals is
unbelievable cutting down trees you know
which are really the lungs
of the planet so so that's one class of
sins but
there's many many other sins that are
being committed immorality
is rampant and so the bible tells us
that god
if people say you know i don't want god
god's not going to push himself
on people he'll simply step back because
he respects freedom of choice yes and
don't you
believe that they're you know we are
messing with the
environment we're messing with you know
these different
instruments that impact the weather and
cause
change you know and we're experimenting
with these things
but we don't really have control we
don't really know what our experiments
are going to lead to and how they're
going to affect
climate i think that's part of the
angels holding back
the consequences of what we're how we're
really impacting the environment and
then at one point
the angel is going to let it go we're
going to see the real consequences of
what we've been doing
right and elon white says there'll be a
scene of strife such as no pen
can picture in other words we think
that's bad now
you know matthew 24 says that there's
going to be wars
and rumors of wars nation against nation
kingdom against kingdom
pestilences earthquakes famines
and you know ellen white states that
these are going to become more and more
frequent and more and more disastrous
so you know there's an agenda behind
this
but it's the devil's agenda it's not the
lord's agenda
the other climate change in history was
the big one was in the days of elijah
three and a half years where it didn't
rain what would happen if it didn't rain
for three and a half years in california
yeah can you imagine it's bad enough
chad's having many years of drought but
no rain at all yeah
yeah so so what would hap what is it
that
caused the heavens to close for three
and a half years
too much air too many air conditioners
there was the wickedness of man again
yes again so so the climate change there
is climate change
there are more and increasing natural
disasters
but the reason is not
the reason that it's being given right
there's a deeper reason than that
but we need the bottom line we need to
care for the environment as christians
we need to be in the forefront amen of
caring for nature amen
well i don't know if we have time uh
let's just try and do this one this last
one we have like four minutes left
okay in the program um
this question is um not directly a bible
well
indirectly it's a bible question okay
i'm a little confused and i need
clarification
i am an independent missionary and i
care very much for my little village sda
church
in central america jesus says to pay
uh to caesar what is caesar's and to god
what is god's
does not the 501c3
contradict this idea uh and thank you
very much for the answer so
the question is uh 501c3 what is 501c3
anyway
501c3 is a non-profit status it allows
a ministry it allows a lot of different
types of ministries
hospitals but it allows christian
ministries to operate
tax exempt so that they can get
donations
from contributors and they can write a
tax-exempt
uh receipt for that and the the
contributor can take that off their
taxes
and the 501c3 is a special status you
have to apply for you have to be
approved for it by the government
uh is it wrong no it's not wrong in this
sense
and there are a lot of biblical examples
of this
that everything in this world is really
owned by god he owns the cattle on a
thousand hills and we are all just
stewards and sometimes
even though they're not believers god
will impress
the heathen to support his cause and we
see this all through the bible when
moses
and the and the hebrews left egypt the
egyptians
gave them uh wealth spoils gold
all kinds of valuables and and part of
that was to make up for their slavery
you know for all the years they've been
in slavery
and so and and and god uh this was used
to build a sanctuary eventually of
course
first of all he was an idol but
eventually was used to build a sanctuary
and and then you see also you see this
um
with cyrus we talked about a little bit
with the sabbath school and how god
impressed his heart to provide for the
building
again of the sanctuary and and even the
romans pagan rome
invested in the temple in christ's day
they had invested they didn't want that
temple destroyed it was one of the
wonders of the world and they did all
they could to preserve
their investment but you also see it in
our history
one of the oldest missionaries in
missionary
places in africa is uh solution college
sales university i should say and when
it was rhodesia
before it became zimbabwe there was a
south african company that
was offering to donate land to
missionaries if they would go in and
cultivate it and
you know teach the the natives and there
was a big to-do about this in our church
you know and haskell wrote to ellen
white and said hey you know we're
there's a couple guys here i think one
of them was jones that was thinking we
shouldn't do this church and state unity
and ellen white said no
no no god will impress and move upon the
hearts of
even the heathen to donate to his cause
accept it and they did
and so this university is the result of
that and i think the important point at
this point
is that the government does not
interfere at all
in the operations of secrets unsealed in
some tv
the day will come when the government
will right we know that right you know
we'll
not only lose our status we'll have to
flee yes
but but right now the government doesn't
tell us well you can't say that or you
can't do that or you can't fundraise
you can't preach that no we are totally
free
but there's the advantage that people
that donate to the ministry can get
a tax-free exempt donation yes and so
basically right now there's no problem
with
having a 501c3 it's just rendering to
caesar when it's caesar's
and caesar up till now is rendered to
god what is god yes
so anyway we see this we see it as
temporary we know it's temporary but
uh and we know it's we're gonna lose it
at some time yeah um but anyway for
anyone who has questions if you'd like
to to send those questions to tv
suntv.org
we'd be happy to attempt to answer those
questions we hope that you've been
blessed by the answers we've been able
to give
in these last few minutes god bless you
until next time
[Music]
you